so these are both ways that you will see
limit based definitions of derivatives
usually this is usually if you're
thinking about the derivative at a point
here if you're thinking about the
derivative in general but these are both
equivalent this they're both based on
the slope of a tangent line or the
instantaneous rate of change and using
these I want to establish some of the
core properties of derivatives for us
and the first one that I'm going to do
will seem like common sense or maybe it
will once we talk about a little bit so
if f of X if our function is equal to a
constant value
well then f prime of X is going to be
equal to zero now why does that make
intuitive sense well we could graph it
we could graph it so if that's my y-axis
that's my x-axis
if I wanted to graph y equals f of X
it's going to look like that
where this is at the value Y is equal to
K so this is y is equal to f of X notice
no matter what you change X Y does not
change the slope of the tangent line
here well frankly is the same line it
has the slope of 0 no matter how Y is
just not changing here and we could use
either of these definitions to establish
that even further establish it using
these these limit definitions so let's
let's see the limit as H approaches 0 of
f of X plus h well no matter what we
input into our function we get K so f of
X plus h would be K minus f of X well no
matter what we put into that function we
get K over H well this is just going to
be 0 over H so this limit is just going
to be equal to 0 so f prime of X for any
for any X the derivative is 0 and you
see that here that this is the slope of
the tangent line for any X is equal to 0
so someone walks up to you on the street
and says ok
H of X H of X H of X is equal to PI what
is H prime of X well you say well PI
it's just a constant value that the
value of our function is not changing as
we change our X the slope of the tangent
line there the instantaneous rate of
change it is going to be equal to zero